les caisses automatiques dans la grande
distribution
vous avez testé la première fois que je
les ai vus c'était à genève je me suis
dit dans une ville cosmopolite c'est
bien normal qu'il y ait des caisses
automatiques effectivement un peu moins
de personnes à la vente un peu plus dans
quelque chose de dynamique quand les
caisses automatiques sont arrivés en
valais j'ai eu un grand dilemme que
faire privilégiez les caisses
traditionnelles essayer de sauvegarder
des emplois de caissier de caissière ou
passer par les caisses automatiques qui
apportait aussi quelque peu de
nouveautés j'ai réfléchi je me suis dit
lise pas possible disant que tu es dans
la réinsertion professionnelle
tu connais la grande distribution tu
sais à quel point elle ouvre les portes
à toutes les personnes qui sont
réinsertion tu continues et même s'il ya
quelques files d'attentes tu passes par
l'endroit où il ya une personne qui te
dis bonjour c'est ce que j'ai fait c'est
ce que j'ai fait jusqu'à un jour où ce
fameux jour où je suis arrivé
effectivement avec ma pause de midi mon
sandwich ma boisson et puis mon chocolat
et puis j'ai constaté que les fils 15
minutes d'attentes en tout cas celle d'à
côté neuf personnes au lieu de 10 que
faire je me suis dit bon eh ben je vais
tester mais j'espère surtout que
personne ne me connaît sait que personne
ne voit que moi je passe par la fis les
caisses automatiques je ne favorise pas
celle où y'a quelqu'un j'ai donc passer
par la caisse automatique et je me suis
rendu compte que c'était très facile que
c'était ludique qui quand il était petit
n'a pas essayé de n'a pas rêvé de passer
au scanner les produits qu'ils avaient
donc voilà j'ai trouvé ça sympa un jeu
d'enfant et d'ailleurs quand je retourne
avec mes enfants pour venin pas de
question et des caisses automatiques
c'est leur génération
on passe par cette avance est là et là
je me suis rappelé ça m'a fait un sacré
un sacré dilemme et puis ça crie
réflexion je me suis rappelé à l'époque
où j'étais à l'école et ils vont parler
de l'arrivée des nouveaux moyens de
transport du train de l'arrivée aussi
des voitures
tout ça dans les siècles passés et sais
pas si vous avez eu également du ca vous
souvenez peut-être à l'époque les gens
avaient de nombreuses peurs mais des
peurs qui aujourd'hui nous paraissent
ridicules
par exemple pour la voiture
avec ce genre de dessin qui apparaissait
dans la presse l'ouragan du siècle où
l'intrusion d'une voiture sans cheval
dans un paisible village la ruine en
perspective
voilà quelle est l approche à l'époque
par rapport à l'arrivée de la voiture
par rapport au train tout le monde avait
peur qu'à 30 km heure on puisse avoir
par exemple des troubles épileptique
qu'une femme puisse accoucher en allant
30 kilomètres ça puisse provoquer des
fausses couches ou autre aujourd'hui ça
nous fait sourire toutes ses peurs à
l'époque c'était quelque chose qui était
partagée et je me suis dit que
finalement ce que j'avais fait c'était
exactement la même chose en continuant à
passer par les fils que je voyais en
écoulant éviter en fait de passer par
des nouvelles technologies j'étais en
train d'avoir exactement la même
réaction qu'à l'époque quand les
nouveaux moyens de transport sont
arrivés hélas pour moi ça a été la
première lumière le premier éclairage
qui m'a fait changer parce que je me
suis rendu compte en passant par les
caisses automatiques qui la dose postes
de travail qui sont créées si vous y
passez vous constatez qu'il ya des
personnes qui sont là pour nous aider à
verjux ou tout à coup la dernière fois
j'ai bloqué le lac est chez manor est
plus trop comment faire mais
effectivement quelqu'un est venu m'aider
m'a aidé à débloquer tout ça il faut les
crée aussi ses caisses il faut rentrer
aussi des nouveaux des nouvelles
indications et autres donc des nouvelles
places de travail
il y en a aussi mais ma capacité à voir
des opportunités plutôt que vouloir
tirer en arrière pour rester dans ce qui
était traditionnels pour moi ça fait un
sacré changement de regard
c'était mon premier éclairage mon
deuxième éclairage je le dois à
quelqu'un de différent
hugo aurions peut-être que vous
connaissez ou goriot hugo rios c'est
quelqu'un qui est autiste qui jusqu'à 6
ans est resté dans un profond mutisme
qui ne parlait pas qui ne communiquait
pas aujourd'hui hugo orio non seulement
il écrit mais il est comédien également
et il milite beaucoup pour le droit des
autistes il a des phrases qui sont très
fortes il utilise toujours des mots qui
sont très forts et qui me parle beaucoup
quand il parle de l'insertion
professionnelle hugo rios dick par
exemple cerveau autiste est
naturellement prédisposé pour comprendre
l'intelligence artificielle il dit aussi
que quelqu'un qui est autiste de rentrer
dans les normes soucier
aujourd'hui c'est quelque chose de
vraiment très difficile passer un
entretien d'embauché pour une personne
autiste c'est impensable
par contre sur le lieu de travail elle
est tout à fait capable d'avoir une
productivité en fonction du cahier des
tâches qui lui est demandé il a une
phrase particulière que j'aime beaucoup
chez hugo orio je vous laisse la
découvrir une société qui ignorent ces
intelligences différentes
est une société qui se met elle-même en
situation de handicap
pour moi cet éclairage est très
différent enfin souvent des personnes
autisme comme est en situation
d'handicap comme étant en dehors notre
société est ce que dit hugo rios celle
inverse c'est qu'en fait en mettant ces
personnes en dehors c'est la société
elle même qui aujourd'hui est en train
de se mettre en situation de handicap
les différences vous en connaissez tous
peut-être que l'autisme c'est quelque
chose de vraiment particulier qui vous
parle un peu moins vous ne connaissez
peut-être pas des personnes autistes par
contre des personnes différentes vous en
connaissez tous différentes par leur
culture par leur ethnie par leur
religion par par aussi si vous voyez
dans les jeunes aujourd'hui pour ceux
qui sont dans l'enseignement n'a de plus
en plus de jeunes qui souffrent de
troubles de l'attention de problème 10
dyslexique et autres je crois que ces
différences ont toujours fait partie en
lait mais peut être un peu plus en
évidence
d'ailleurs vous avez regardé votre
voisin vous avez vu regarder prenez le
temps de regarder vos voisins pas celui
droite que vous connaissez celui de
gauche vous connaissez pas voilà vous
avez vu votre voisin il est différent
effectivement et puis ces différences je
crois que c'est vraiment une richesse
donc si vous ne connaissez pas votre
voisin n'hésitez pas profité de la pause
ensuite posez lui des questions pour
connaître ces différences ces
différences ont certainement si des
points forts dans sa vie de tous les
jours et puis la culture des différences
ça me fait penser aussi à quelqu'un
quelqu'un qui s'appelle balle comme
gareth la douelle qui a aussi eu la
chance de participer à un pied d' x et
lorsqu'il parle de la différence alors
le le rapport peut vous paraître un peu
loin avec le marché du travail mais il
parle des tomates des sauces tomate et
il dit que en fait les sauces tomate
on n'est pas tous programmés pour aimer
la même sauce tomate ya ceux qui
préfèrent une sauce tomate avec des
morceaux ceux qui préfèrent une sauce
tomate
c et puis que c'est justement cette
différence si l'industrie alimentaire
s'était focalisée sur un seul type de
force sauce tomate
on n'aurait pas tous les goûts il y
aurait pas tous les développements qu'on
a aujourd'hui on ne répondrait pas aux
attentes des clients
c'est justement la diversité qui fait
qu'on peut répondre aux besoins des
clients et qui fait qu'on peut réussir
dans l'industrie alors lui parlait des
sauces tomate mois les sauces tomate ça
me parle mais pas tellement quand je
pense à la différence ex pense à tout ce
qui est alimentaire
l'image qui me vient à l'esprit c'est
celle celle des yogourts si l'industrie
développe autant du yogourt différent
c'est pas parce que tout le monde va
acheter des yogourts moka pour ma part
je déteste les yogourts moka donc j'y
réponds acheter des recours au cas donc
je suis content d'avoir choix entre
autres choses mais si ça fonctionne qui
a autant de choix c'est parce que nous
parce que vous parce tout le monde a des
goûts différents et qu'on est capable de
les mettre en avant et de les vendre
alors le rapport avec le marché du
travail pourquoi est ce qu'il en serait
autrement dans le marché du travail
pourquoi est ce que pour travailler on
doit tous rentrer dans une case excel où
ça a été défini qu'il faut hôtel
formation qu'il faut telles compétences
qu'il faut voilà tel parcours pour
pouvoir répondre à une place qui a été
qui a été mise en avant
non j'y crois pas je pense que justement
que la différence la différence des gens
c'est ce qui fait ce qui fait la
richesse aussi du monde professionnel
notre monde est en train d'évoluer dans
ce sens là c'est là aussi ma deuxième
lumière le monde évolue et on a déjà des
choses que l'on voit notamment gpt en
travaillant dans la formation
professionnelle à fribourg par exemple
dans le bio farma on a des entreprises
qui nous demandent de sélectionner les
personnes qui veulent travailler dans
leur entreprise
non pas sur le curiculum vitae non pas
sur la formation
mais uniquement en pouvant les analyser
quelles sont leurs compétences et
comment elles vont pouvoir s'introduire
dans ce travail là et c'est ça qui fait
qu'ensuite les entreprises vont les
former c'est des choses qui existent
déjà qui sont en train de changer
à genève on a aussi une entreprise ont
parlé avant de des personnes autistes
on a une entreprise à genève qui
engagent des personnes autistes
non pas pour les mettre dans des postes
occupationnel pour faire je dirais pour
donner bonne conscience mais vraiment
parce qu'elles ont des capacités que
nous personne normale
non pas du tout et c'est cette capacité
là qui sont mises en valeur dans l'antre
fessionnels j'ai aussi entendu
dernièrement à neuchâtel un projet d'une
entreprise une agence de placement qui
aimerait créer uniquement avec des
profils différents
donc je suis convaincu que le regard
qu'on peut avoir aussi sur notre société
le regard qu'on peut ouvrir en se disant
que même s'il a des personnes
différentes
le monde professionnel peut les intégrer
c'est quelque chose qui nous fait
évoluer de là mon idée c'est vrai qu'en
évaluant la danse est un changement qui
est perpétuelle c'est pas quelque chose
qui acquit pouvoir se remettre en
question en permanence sur les
changements qui arrivent pour art se
dire en permanence d'une part première
lumière
je suis capable de voir tout ce qui
bouge tous qui évolue malgré toutes les
peurs qu'on entend aujourd'hui en disant
que la digitalisation va tout changer
si je suis capable de voir tout cela
comme une opportunité c'est le premier
éclairage
si l'autre côté je suis capable de voir
les êtres humains avec leurs différences
comme une richesse supplémentaire et que
je mets ces deux choses ensemble je suis
convaincu que mon regard son marché du
travail évolue et si moi j'y arrive vous
y arriver aussi
[Applaudissements]